bon on passe au cyclisme tour de france
12e étape aujourd'hui 12 juillet c'est
normal entrepris de la gaillarde et
bordeaux victoire d'un américain au
sprint à boire debout
oui aux politiques au gagnant gagnant
très français garde le maillot jaune
marcia lins le gagnant mais ce qu'on
retiendra surtout le cdh est là pour dix
ans et la chute et l'abandon de sean
kelly qui était l'un des favoris
pierre pradinas 50e kilomètre le peloton
et près de sarlat un attroupement du
mouvement un homme le dr portes seront
sur le lieu du drame
vous l'avez reconnu sean kelly y en est
la victime courageux irlandais remonte
sur son vélo
aidé par ses coéquipiers et au prix d'un
fantastique et fort le favori du tour
repart par pour longtemps
malheureusement 20 km 20 km d'horreur
c'en est trop la douleur l'emportent
kelly le maudit s'arrête
diagnostic fracture de la clavicule
après le tour d'espagne et paris roubaix
le tour de france
c'en est fini pour kevin l'histoire de
cette 12e étape retiendrons donc
l'abandon de kelly la victoire au sprint
de david phinney et le maintien du
maillot jaune sur les épaules du
français martial gayant
au menu de demain les premiers cols de
montagne